one of the lesser discussed members of
the Axis powers during World War two is
Bulgaria which had allied itself with
Germany in the Central Powers in the
previous war which had gone really
really well at first after the first
world war was over Bulgaria along with
the other losers lost a fair bit of
territory which to be blunt they wanted
back Bulgaria had been having some
internal problems and was currently
under the personal rule of Tsar Boris
the third Boris had spent the 1930s
neutering the Army's political influence
in which many had communist sympathies
and had began a series of political
reforms these reforms culminated in
national elections in which communists
were forbidden from voting or running in
the pro boris faction of the government
was victorious this government sought to
reverse Bulgari's ongoing international
isolation to strengthen the country that
doesn't mean the bulgaria was willing to
be friends with everyone though when the
USSR offered to assist bulgaria by
supporting his claims to southern de
bruza unsurprisingly boris said no
because czars and communism don't mix
when the second world war broke out in
1939 bulgaria was pretty keen to stay
out of it and declared its neutrality
immediately it wasn't long into the
world that Bulgaria with the backing of
Italy was able to push for the return of
southern to brujah and this was handed
back to them on September the 7th 1944
the Bulgaria could gain a lot from
cooperation with the axis also Bulgaria
was becoming ever more reliant on trade
with Germany for two reasons
the first was that German support was
needed to modernize Bulgaria's aging
armament industry the second was the
international trade had the flow through
the Black Sea in the Bosphorus meaning
that it could be stopped by the USSR in
Turkey they spent that when Mussolini
promised this territory in return for
aiding his coming invasion of Greece
Bulgaria would have greater access to
trade a counteroffer was made by Stalin
which offered these lands to Bulgaria in
return for Bulgaria allowing Soviet
troops to be stationed there again Boris
said no because he had seen what had
happened to the Baltic States when they
allowed Soviet troops to be stationed
there he also said no to Mussolini
because Boris was staunchly against any
war Mussolini invaded without Bulgarian
help and it did not go well as such
Hitler wanted to send German troops
through Bulgaria in order to put an end
to Greek resistance and also to end
Yugoslavia because why not
Bulgaria couldn't exactly resist the
Germans are so Boris and the government
opted to join the Axis powers and assist
as thanks for their assistance Bulgaria
was gifted these lands which confirmed
too many that an alliance with Germany
was for the best
whilst Germany had allowed Bulgaria to
join the
axis it was mostly due to convenience in
fact Germany's political leadership
never grew to trust the Bulgarians fully
throughout the entire war there were a
few reasons for this there was a concern
that Bulgaria would simply take its new
territories and just leave the axis
because it didn't want to fight concern
number two was the fact that Bulgaria
had refused to implement the anti-jewish
laws that Germany had demanded of the
other members of the axis whilst Jews
were deported from the new territories
by the German troops that had conquered
them Tsar Boris and the higher-ups in
the Orthodox Church made sure to defy
the orders to deport Jews from Bulgaria
proper the third concern was the immense
pro-russian sentiment across Bulgaria
which would become much more important
in a mere few months in fact when
Germany did invade the USSR Bulgaria
didn't join them and even maintain
diplomatic relations with it that said
things still ended pretty poorly for
Bulgaria though I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
extra thanks to my patrons that you see
on screen now and a special thanks to
James Bissonnette party Boyko Zarqa
flash chris wicker Rob Waterhouse
Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan Meggie pax
Kowski Winston k-word rafail Adam Harvey
Anthony Beckett Skye Chappell and the
amusement park Ives
you